WAHID BHIMJI: OK, so I'm Wahid.
I'm not actually part of Google.
I'm at Lawrence
Berkeley National Lab.
And I'm sort of
going to tell you
how we're using
TensorFlow to perform
deep learning for the
fundamental sciences
and also using
high-performance computing.
OK, so the
fundamental sciences--
particle physics,
cosmology, and lots
of other things I'll
explain in a minute--
make heavy use of
high-performance computing
at the center I
work at, which is
part of the
Department of Energy,
initially for simulation
and data analysis,
or traditionally.
But progress in deep learning
and tools like TensorFlow
have really enabled the use
of higher-dimensional data
and through deep learning
enable the possibility
of new discoveries, faster
computation, and actually
whole new approaches.
And I'm going to
talk about that here,
illustrating with a
few examples of stuff
we're running at NERSC.
So what is NERSC?
It's the high-performance
computing center
for the Department of
Energy Office for Science,
which means we support the
whole breadth of science
that the DoE does, which
actually includes things like
not just cosmology or what
you might think of as energy
research, like batteries
and so forth, but also
materials and climate and
genomics and things like this.
So we have a huge range
of users and a vast range
of projects across a
whole variety of science.
And we have big machines.
Cori, our latest machine was
number five, and, in fact,
the highest by P flops in
the US when it was installed
a couple of years ago.
But things dropped
down those numbers,
and now it's number
10 in the top 500.
OK, so we see the use of AI
now across the whole science
domain.
So you probably can't
see this slide very well,
but this is a take on an
industry part of machine
learning, sort of splitting
it into supervised learning
and unsupervised learning, and
classification and regression,
and so forth.
And there's kind
of examples here
that we see across the sciences.
But I'll be mostly talking about
particle physics and cosmology
because actually
that's my background.
So I'm more comfortable
with those examples.
So what we're trying
to do in these fields
is really uncover the
secrets of the universe.
So this is a sort of
evolution from the Big
Bang to the present day.
And there's planets
and galaxies and stuff.
And they've all been
influenced by, for example,
dark matter and dark
energy over this evolution.
So obviously our
understanding of this
has come a long way
in recent years.
But there's still plenty
of mysteries and things
that we don't know about,
like the very things I just
mentioned, like dark matter.
What is the nature
of dark matter?
And what is the relationship
between particle physics that
explains extremely well
the very small, and even
everything around us,
but yet, breaks down
at cosmological scales?
So in order to answer
those kind of questions,
we have huge
complex instruments,
such as the planned LSST
telescope on the left,
which is going to look at
the very big in resolutions
that currently I'm presenting.
And the ATLAS
Detector at the LHC
on the right, which is at
the Large Hadron Collider,
so at the Swiss,
French border, it's
a detector the
size of a building.
There's little people there.
You can sort of see them.
And it has hundreds of millions
of channels of electronics
to record collisions that
occur in the middle every 25
nanoseconds, so a
huge stream of data.
So both of these experiments
have vast streams of data.
Really the ATLAS experiment
has processed exabytes
of data over its time.
And this has to be filtered
through a process of data
analysis and so forth.
And so if you get like
high-resolution images or very
detailed detector
outputs, the first stage
is to kind of
simplify these, maybe
build catalogs of
objects in the sky,
such as stars and galaxies, or
in the case of particle physics
to kind of combine these into
what particles might have been
produced, and these lines
or tracks and deposits that
have occurred in the detector.
So this obviously also involves
a large amount of computing.
So computing fits in here.
But computing also
fits in because the way
that these analyses are done is
to compare with simulated data,
in this case cosmology
simulations that
are big HPC simulations done
for different types of universes
that might have
existed depending
on different
cosmology parameters.
And in the particle
physics case,
you do extremely
detailed simulations
because of the
precision you require
in terms of how
the detector would
have reacted to, for example,
a particle coming in here.
So here you've got all
this kind of showering
of what would have happened
inside the detector.
And then from each
of these, you might
produce summary statistics
and compare one to the other
and what are secrets
of the universe,
I guess, such as the
nature of dark matter,
or new particles at the LHC.
OK, so you might
have guessed there's
many areas where deep
learning can help with this.
So one is classification
to, for example,
find those physics objects
that I showed identified
in collisions at the LHC.
Or, indeed, just
to directly find
from the raw data what
was interesting and what
was not interesting.
Another way you might use it
is regression to, for example,
find what kind of energies were
deposited inside the detector
or what were the
physics parameters that
were responsible for stuff
that you saw in the images
at the telescopes.
Another is sort of
clustering feature detection
in a more unsupervised
way, where
you might want to look
for anomalies in the data,
either because these
are signs of new physics
or because they're actually
problems with the instruments.
And then another
last way, perhaps,
is to generate data to replace
the full physics simulations
that I just described,
which are, as I mentioned,
extremely computationally
expensive.
So I'll give a few examples
across these domains, OK?
So the first is classification.
So there you're trying
to answer the question,
is this new physics?
For example,
supersymmetry, which
is also a dark matter candidate.
So I could give you
the answer later
whether that's actually
new physics or not.
So here the idea is kind of be--
there's several papers
now that are exploiting
this kind of idea is
to take the detector,
like the ATLAS detector,
and sort of unroll--
so it's a cylindrical detector
with many cylindrical layers,
and to take that and unroll
it into an image where
you have phi along
here, which is
the angle around this direction,
and eta this way, which
is a physicist's
way of describing
the forwardness of the deposit.
And then just simply
put it in an image,
and then you get
the ability to use
all of the kind of developments
in image recognition,
such as convolutional
neural networks.
So here's what is now a
relatively simple sort
of convolutional network,
several convolution and pooling
layers, and then fully
connected layers.
And we've exploited
this at scales,
either taking 64 by
64 images to represent
this, or at the 224
by 224, sort of closer
to the resolution
of the detector.
And then you can also
have multiple channels
which correspond
to different layers
of this cylindrical detector.
And we saw that
it kind of works.
So here you have a rock curve
of the two class probability,
so false positive rate.
So the first thing
to notice is that you
need a very, very high
rejection of the physics
that you already know about
because that vastly dominates.
So actually, the data's even
been prefiltered before this.
So you need a low
false positive rate.
And generally, of course,
in these rock curves,
higher this way is better.
So this point represents
the physics selections
that were traditionally
used in this analysis.
These curves here, like
incorporating those higher
level physics variables.
But in shallow neural
net-- in shallow machine
learning approaches.
And then the blue
line shows that you
can gain quite a lot,
and this from using
convolution neural networks,
which gives you access.
It's not just the
technique of deep learning,
but also being able to use
all the data that's available.
And then, similarly,
there's another boost
from using three channels,
which corresponds
to the other detectors.
OK, so I'd just like to
caveat a few of these results.
So even though there's
obvious gains to be had here,
these analyses are
still not currently used
in the Large Hadron
Collider analyses.
And part of the
reason for that is
because this is trained
on simulation, whereas--
and it might pick up on very
small aspects of the simulation
that differ from the real data.
So there's several
work that's carrying on
from this to look at
how to incorporate
real data into what's done.
But also, I think
methodological developments
in how to interrogate
these models,
and really discover
what they're learning
would be kind of
useful for the field.
OK, so taking a
regression problem now,
the kind of question
you might ask
is, what possible universe
would look like this?
So this is an image from the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey.
So here the Earth's
in the middle,
and increasing redshift
takes you out this way.
So this is like the
older universe over here.
And you can kind of see.
And the histogram is a
structure of galaxies' density.
So there's like
more-- you can see
that structure sort of appears
as the universe evolves.
And that kind of
evolution of structure
tells you something about
the cosmology parameters
that were involved.
So can you actually
regress those parameters
from looking at these
kind of distributions?
So the idea here was
to take a method that
was developed by these people
in CMU, which is to use, again,
a convolutional neural network.
But here, running on a 3D--
this is actually simulated
data, so 3D distribution
of dark matter in the universe.
And these can be large datasets.
So part of the work we did here
was to kind of scale this up
and run on extremely large data
and across the kind of machines
we have at Cori on
8,000 CPU nodes,
which is kind of some
of the largest scale
that TensorFlow has been run
on in a data parallel fashion,
and then being able to predict
cosmology parameters that
went into this simulation in
a matter of minutes because
of the scale of
computation used.
So, again, it's a
fairly standard network,
but this time in 3D.
And actually, there
was quite a bit
of work to get this to work
well on CPU, for example.
Because that's-- sorry, I
should have mentioned, actually,
that the machine that we have
is primarily composed of Intel
Knights Landing CPU.
So that's another area
that we help develop.
OK, so again, it kind of works.
And so here they like
to plot the true value
of the parameter
that's being regressed
against the predicted value.
So you hope that it would
match up along the line.
And, indeed, the
points which come
from a run of this
regression do actually
lie across this line
in all the cases.
Now, the actual crosses come
from the larger-scale run.
So the points come from a
2,000 node run of the network,
and the crosses come
from an 8,000 node run.
So the sort of caveat here is
that the 8,000 node run doesn't
actually do as well as the
2,000 node run, which kind of
indicates a point, which is
another thing we're working on
about convergence of
these neural networks
when running at a large
distributed scale.
So I'll come back to
that a bit later as well.
OK, so then the last example I
have here is around generation.
So, as I mentioned,
simulations went
into that previous
analysis, and they
go into all of the
kind of analyses
that are done at these--
for these kind of purposes.
But in order to get some
of these simulations,
it actually takes two
weeks of computational time
on a large supercomputer
of the scale of Cori,
which is kind of a
huge amount of resource
to be giving over to these.
And for different
versions of the cosmology
that you want to
generate, you need
to do more of these simulations.
And part of the output that
you might get from these
is, this is a 2D mass
map, which corresponds
to the actual
galaxy distribution
that you might
observe from data.
So this is what you would
want to compare with data.
So the question is, is it
possible to augment your data
set and generate
different cosmologies
in a kind of fast simulation
that doesn't require running
this full infrastructure?
And the way that
we tried to do that
was to use generative
adversarial networks that
were mentioned briefly in
the last talk, where you have
two networks that work
in tandem with each other
and that are optimized together,
but against each other,
and one is trying to tell
the difference between.
So the advantage here is that
we have some real examples
from the full simulation
to compare with.
And the discriminator
can take those and say,
does the generator do any good
job of producing fake maps?
And we used a pretty
standard DCGAN architecture.
And there was a few
modifications in this paper
to make that work.
But at the time last year
there weren't many people
trying to apply this.
One of the other applications
that was being done at the time
is actually to the
particle physics
problem from other
people at Berkeley Lab.
And, again, it works.
And so the top plot
is a validation set
of images that weren't
used in the training.
And the bottom is
the generated images.
I mean, the first
time cosmologists
saw this, they were kind
of pretty well surprised
that they couldn't tell the
difference between them,
because they weren't
really expecting
us to be able to do so
well that they wouldn't
be able to tell by eye.
But you certainly
can't tell by eye.
But one of the advantages of
working with this in science,
as opposed to
celebrity faces, is
that we do actually have
good metrics for determining
whether we've done well enough.
So the top right is
the power spectrum,
which is something often
used by cosmologists,
but it's just the
Fourier transform
of a two-point correlation.
So it sort of represents
the Gaussian fluctuations
in the plot.
And here you can see the
black is the validation,
and the pink is the GAN.
And so it not only agrees on the
mean, this kind of middle line,
but it also captures the
distribution of this variable.
And it's not just
two-point correlations.
But the plot on the
right shows something
called the Minkowski
functional, which
is a form with a
three-point correlation.
So even non-Gaussian structures
in these maps are reproduced.
And the important
point, I guess,
is that you could just sample
from these distributions
and reproduce those well.
But all this was trained on
was to reproduce the images.
And it got these kind of
structures, the physics that's
important, right?
OK, so this is very promising.
But obviously, the
holy grail of this
is really to be able to do
this for different values
of the initial cosmology, sort
of parameterized generation,
and that's what we're
working towards now.
OK, so I mentioned
throughout that we
have these big computers.
So another part of
what we're trying to do
is use extreme computing
scales in a data parallel way
to train these things
faster, so not just
different hyperparameters,
which, of course,
people also do, is to train
different hyperparameters
on different nodes
in our computer,
but just to train also
one model quicker.
And we've done that for
all of these examples
here so that the one
on the left is the LHC
CNN, which I described first.
So I should say also
that we have a large Cray
machine that has an optimized
high-performance network.
But that network has been
particularly optimized
for HPC simulations and stuff
and MPI-based architectures.
So really it's been a huge
gain for this kind of work
that these plug-ins
now exist that allow
you to do MPI-distributed
training, such as Horovod
from Uber.
And also Cray have developed a
machine-learning plug-in here.
So we used that
for this problem.
And you can basically see
that all the lines kind of
follow the ideal scaling
up to thousands of nodes.
And so you can really
process more data faster.
So there's quite a bit
of engineering work
that goes into this, of course.
And this is shown
in the papers here.
For the LHC CNN, there's
still a gap between the ideal.
And that's partly
because it's not
such a computationally
intensive model.
So I/O and stuff
becomes more important.
For the CosmoGAN on the
right, that's the GAN example.
And there it is a bit more
computationally intensive.
So it does follow the
scaling curve here.
And CosmoFlow I just
put in the middle here.
I mean, here we show
that I/O was important.
But we were able to
exploit something we have,
which is this burst buffer,
which is a layer of SSDs that
sits on the high-speed network.
And we were much
more able to scale up
to the scale of the full
machine, 8,000 nodes using
that than the shared
disc space file system.
OK, so another area that I
just wanted to briefly mention
at the end is that we have
these fancy supercomputers,
but as I mentioned, this
takes a lot of engineering.
And it was projects that
we work particularly with.
Something that we
really want to do
is allow people to use the
supercomputer scale of kind
of deep learning via
Jupyter notebooks,
which is really how
scientists prefer to interact
with our machines these ways.
So we do provide
JupyterHub at NERSC.
But generally what
people are running
sits on a dedicated machine
outside the main compute
infrastructure.
But what we did here was
to enable them to run stuff
actually on the
supercomputing machine, either
using ipyparallel or Dask, which
are tools used for distributed
computing, but interfacing
with this via the notebook,
and where a lot of
the heavy computation
actually occurs with the MPI
backend in Horovod and stuff.
So we were able to show that
you can scale to large scales
here without adding any
extra overhead from being
able to interact.
And then, of course, you
can add nice Jupyter things,
like widgets and
buttons, so that you
can run different hyperparameter
trials and sort of click
on them and display
them in the pane there.
OK, so I just have
my conclusion now.
Basically deep
learning, particularly
in combination with
high-performance computing,
but productive software
like TensorFlow,
can really accelerate science.
And we've seen that
in various examples.
I only mentioned a few here.
But it requires developments,
not only in methods.
So we have other
projects where we're
working with
machine-learning researchers
to develop new methods.
Also, there's different ways
of applying these, of course.
And we're well-placed
to do that.
And also well-placed to do
some of the computing work.
But it can really benefit
from collaboration, I think,
between scientists and the
industry, which is sort
of better represented here.
And we've had a good
relationship with Google there.
But I think we can also
do that with others.
So basically my last
slide is a call to help.
If you have any
questions, but also
if you have ideas
or collaborations
or want to work with
us on these problems,
that would be good
to hear about.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WAHID BHIMJI: Yeah.
Well, what was I going to
say about supersymmetry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHS]
WAHID BHIMJI: Well, yeah,
I don't think it's real.
But no, I guess I was going
to say whether or not--
so this example
isn't supersymmetry.
I can tell you that.
But yeah, part of the point
of this network, I guess,
is it vastly improves our
sensitivity to supersymmetry.
So hopefully it could
help answer the question
if it's real or not.
But yeah, certainly
there's no current evidence
at the Large Hadron Collider,
so that's why we keep looking.
And also I would say that
some of these approaches
also might help you look in
different ways, for example,
not being so
sensitive to the model
that theorists
have come up with.
So this approach really
trains on simulated samples
of a particular model that
you're looking out for.
But some of the ways that
we're trying to extend this
is to be more of a sort
of anomaly detection,
looking for things that you
might not have expected.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WAHID BHIMJI: Yeah, so the thing
with these big collaborations
that work at the LHC is they're
very sensitive about you
working on the real data.
So, for example, someone
who's coming from outside
can't just apply this
model on the real data.
You have to work within
the collaboration.
So the reason why
they don't use things
like this in the
collaboration at the moment
is partly just because
of the kind of rigor
that goes into
cross-validating and checking
that all these
models are correct.
And that just takes a bit
of time for it to percolate.
There's a little
bit of a skepticism
amongst certain people
about new ideas, I guess.
And so I think the
fact that this has now
been demonstrated in
several studies sort of
adds a bit of
mitigation to that.
But then the other
reason, I think,
is that there's another
practical reason, which
is that this was exploiting
kind of the full raw data.
And apart from-- there are
sort of practical reasons
why you wouldn't
want to do that,
because these are large
hundreds of petabyte datasets.
And so filtering, in terms
of these high-level physics
variables, is not
only done because they
think they know the
physics, but also
because of practicality
of storing the data.
So those are a bunch of reasons.
But then I gave another sort
of technical reason, which
is that you might be
more sensitive to this,
to mismodeling in
the training data.
And they really care about
systematic uncertainties
and so forth.
And those are
difficult to model when
you don't know what it is you're
trying to model for, I guess,
because you don't know what the
network necessarily picked up
on.
And so there's various
ways to mitigate
some of these
technical challenges,
including sort of mixing of
data with simulated data,
and also using different
samples that don't necessarily
have all the same modeling
effects, and things like that.
So there's a part
that's cultural,
but there's also a
part that's technical.
And so I think we can try and
address the technical issues.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WAHID BHIMJI: Not
directly this model.
But yeah, there is certainly
a huge range of work.
So we mostly work with the
Department of Energy science.
And there's projects
across all of here.
So, I mean, we can
only work in depth,
I guess, with a few projects.
So we have a sort
of few projects
where we work in depth.
But really part of what
our group does at NERSC
is also to make these tools
like TensorFlow working
at scale on the computer
available to the whole science
community.
And so we're having more
and more training events,
and the community
are picking up--
different communities
are picking this up more
by themselves.
And that really allows--
so there certainly
will be groups
working with other parts
of physics, I think.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WAHID BHIMJI: Why is
deep learning, right?
I mean, it's not really
the only approach.
So like this actual
diagram doesn't just
refer to deep learning.
So some of these
projects around the edge
here are not using
deep learning.
My talk was just about a
few deep learning examples.
So it's not necessarily
the be all and end all.
I think one of the
advantages is that there
is a huge amount of development
work in methods in things
like convolution neural networks
and stuff that we can exploit.
Relatively off
the shelf, they're
already available in tools
like TensorFlow and stuff.
So I mean, I think
that's one advantage.
The other advantage is there is
quite a large amount of data.
There are nonlinear
features and stuff
that can be captured by
these more detailed models
and so forth.
So I don't know.
It's not necessarily
the only approach.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WAHID BHIMJI: Yeah, so,
I mean, there certainly
are cases where the current
models are being well tuned,
and they are right.
But there's many cases where
you can get an advantage.
I mean, you might think that the
physics sections here, they're
well tuned over certain years.
They know what the
variables are to look for.
But there is a performance gain.
And it can just be from
the fact that you're
exploiting more
information in the event
that you were otherwise throwing
away, because you thought
you knew everything that was
important about those events,
but actually there
was stuff that
leaked outside, if you like, the
data that you were looking at.
So there are gains to
be had I think, yeah.